pas de doute alors pendant que ce film
vous était présente et nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir martha la mode
c'était encore de la veuve qui charrient
les termes de la veuve pichard là où on
jouait jusqu'à ces derniers jours
un spectacle a très bien marché la
revanche de louis on voit là à ce moment
on fait rien d'ailleurs vous êtes un
travaux pour le prochain spectacle voilà
on fait des trois corps vous n'êtes pas
du tout écouter ce qui s'est dit jusqu'à
présent n'ont sauvé l'honneur
c'était très bien on parlait on peut en
même temps on essaie d'expliquer si vous
voulez comme en avait démarré le café
théâtre est ce que c'était que l'esprit
du café-théâtre et lacan jeu quand je
vois ces deux extraits des deux pièces à
vôtre et celle du café de la gare bon il
ya il ya de ça tire un petit peu à elle
s'attire donc d'un club de vacances et
puis il ya la satire du milieu théâtral
bon alors est ce que c'est parce que
dans le café théâtre on peut dire des
choses qu'on ne veut plus dire dans le
théâtre normal traditionnel oui mais lui
c'est lui je vais vous dire ça c'est
plus cher 4 2 des visions cadre de
satire c'est mal à exprimer
je dirais qu'on va moins loin mais on en
dit plus vaillantes ont une liberté de
langage qui parfois va jusqu'aux gros
mot oui ces théâtres sont des endroits
on entend beaucoup de gros match attend
du sud disent carrément ce que je veux
et ce cas là à ce moment là je peux vous
rapprocher les chansonniers moi ce
serait dangereux relais chancelier ou
pour les autres
peut-être que ça annonce qui risque
d'être groupe plein de choses légales de
cabaret ya le cabaret les chansonniers
de 4 ne s'est pas plaint le boulevard
donc on s'ajuste pas à faire il reçoit
monsieur numérique face à metz b autre
manière je pense que tous les cafés
théâtres qui avait débuté à ces
politiques maintenant c'est fini je
pense que ça dépend il est prévu
d'engager pas connu non mais c'est vrai
que quand même beaucoup la manière de
10h02 charlie hebdo je ne sais pas que
d'autres que je ne sais pas quoi que
j'en ai l'adour et c'est sur c'est sûr
comment vous travaillez comment par
exemple bon alors il ya une troupe ici
représentée par vous de ces salles de
café théâtre le splendide et puis il ya
la veuve pichard comment s'est créé la
troupe du café théâtre le soulevant dit
comment avez vous trouvé moi c'est ça
l'histoire n'ont alors plus policé olic
à l'avancé des connus au lycée on a
appris le métier en chahutant et
professeurs et puis après on a appris il
a joué puis une fois qu'on eut appris à
jouer on s'est dit on va monter un
spectacle mais après appris auprès de
qui oui j'ai quand même pris des cours
des devises pendant 12 ans ça va dire
pas tous tout en jouant et puis certains
autres sont venus qui est pas pris de
court avec elle et puis oui c'est ça eva
la fois amateurs et démarrage de
professionnels ouais je pense pas quand
on sort d'un courant soit un
professionnel
enfin ils ont été brouillées on a joué
au lycée et à la salle vallier pas de
salle bah on a trouvé d'avoir quelqu'un
nous a fait confiance à la vincent
kaldor qui nous a aidés à monter un
autre premier spectacle s'appelle je
vais craquer et movie au café théâtre de
l'odéon dans un cadre rigide et déjà les
autres jacques caf quoi
et puis après on a trouvé un autre
personne n'a dit il nous faut un théâtre
à nous alors on s'est installé en face
du café de la guerre là où ils étaient
avant c'est-à-dire rue d'odessa
montparnasse et avec quel argent comment
faisiez-vous ben là on est en
association avec le type qui possédait
le local prêté à 50% avec ce succès 106
800 mm
les scènes et puis après ça ça l'impasse
allait être détruite
donc on a dit faux concernant et puis on
voulait gagner tout pour nous d'ailleurs
c'est très très typique c'est que les
cafés théâtres sont toujours installées
dans des quartiers est en voie de
disparition c'est dans des quartiers
qu'on allait démolir fois que c'est pour
des raisons simples celle ça coûte moins
cher oui mes entretiens n'a donc eu à
montparnasse il y en a eu beaucoup wall
il y en a eu un beau bourg est très
régulièrement comme ça les change
d'endroit simplement parce qu on
exproprie laquelle est le premier c'est
celui qui le premier a eu l'idée d'aller
s'installer dans un café pour faire du
théâtre c'est la crise au sein de la
halle et ce avec des états unis mais
comment oui oh ben ça remonte déjà on
s'en souvient très peu parce que c'est
il ya très longtemps des trajets sur la
jeune dans le choix qu'il a dû dire
tiens tiens la pâte et attire veut ça
coûte trop cher de monter une pièce
jointe allons la jouer dans un café
c'est aussi la maison frenchy résorbe
non vous on pourrait faire du tas dont
feraient peut-être du temps je sais pas
maintenant ce n'était pas évident parce
que c'est plus proche du cinéma du
théâtre
ah oui mais l'important est ce que vous
êtes en train de dire ça vous arrive est
davantage envie de faire du cinéma du
théâtre parce qu'on joue pas pareil
non j'ai pas compris ce qu'est ce qui
est bien donc je raconte roger l'aube
ces petits on n'a pas besoin de jouer
théâtre on peut jouer le vrai enfin le
port naturel ces frayeurs miu miu et
c'est jacques c'est patrick dewaere
c'est ce qu'a fait le pape du cadavre
d'un goûter
pourquoi le pape devait fêter parce que
c'est ça romain bouteille dès qu'on
parle de café théâtre en france il ya
toujours romain bouteille qui est là à
peu près tout le monde a travaillé avec
romain bouteille on vénère beaucoup
romain bouteille on a un bouddha il
continue à écrire des pièces que les
autres acteurs de café théâtre viennent
me voir c'est au point que lui je crois
que son fils romain quand même c'est une
référence et donc à chaque fois qu'une
bouteille fais quelque chose je crois
que ça influe sur à peu près tout effet
théâtre de paris et même au delà j'ai vu
les présentes dans les blondes au moyen
âge par canton début et c'est vraiment
formidable c'était ce qu'il fallait
révélation salem ne soyez pas vous êtes
entre initiés moi je ne suis pas initier
et j'imagine que tous ceux qui ne
regardent ne sont pas initiés qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
c'était ça qu'il fallait qu'on fasse
qu'est-ce-qu'il décontraction formidable
avait une vérité dans les rayons ils
croyaient d'abord puis c'est trop river
mais mes 100 fois plus que n'importe
quoi quand on avait vu avant mais
n'importe quoi du monde hier à tous on
était allé ouvriers pas tellement et la
cnac en arrière s'est dit tiens ça c'est
pas mal oui langage qui est très
du désert partiellement ça dure l'humour
de romain c'est quand même un truc très
très particulier là il ya quelque chose
qui se passe c'est que bon il ya romain
bouteille qui écrit des pièces pour sa
troupe et pour les autres mais en
définitive d'une manière générale vous
vous écrivez vos pièces vous-même n'ya
pas d'auteur en dehors de romain
bouteille
y'a pas d'auteur spécifique de quelque
chose ça marche a écrit beaucoup sont
pas beaucoup peut-être est-ce que c'est
parce que justement cette espèce de
travail en groupe qui consiste à écrire
en même temps sur une idée qui rapide
est donné par l'électricien le menuisier
ou à des acteurs de la troupe est ce que
nous faisons nous il n'y a pas de
menuisiers électriciens puisqu'on on a
tout fait nous-mêmes sûr qu'on a
construit tout le théâtre donc la notion
de menuisiers électriciens n'existe pas
on est six comédiens on a appris à faire
les travaux on a fait neuf mois de
travaux au splendid
oui on savait rien faire mais on s'est
dit il faut faire on a on nous a dit si
on l'a fait et c'est arrivé c'est pas
très bien de troupes c'est à dire qu'on
a on a une troupe qui toujours la même
un peu de choses près sauf quand ça va
très mal et a donc c'est toujours les
mêmes joueurs donc il faut écrire pour
les mêmes gens donc la manière la plus
simple d'écrire pour eux c'est de leur
demander ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils
voudraient jouer c'est ça alors et à ce
moment là on écrit non peut-être qu'on
écrit tout seul où on écrit ensemble
mais c'est aussi pour ça quelque chose
qui est important si nous pouvons nous
pas comme il n'ya pas de directeur n'y a
pas de chef
c'est important que tous décrivent comme
ça commence comme dans un spectacle ya
quand même des choses qui sont rajoutés
tout le temps d un visa sio un petit peu
sit in aux textes et collectif quand
quelqu'un rajoute quelque chose personne
ne peut lui dire écoute tu te saccage
mon texte
oui c'est ça nan shan à écrire dont il
faut qu'on se réunit souvent pour en
parler mais disons que ça donne l'usc du
brt on peut se permettre un peu tout
c'est peut-être ça la vraie création
s'il faut appuyer à moi je pense
aujourd'hui c'est le design mais nous en
tout cas c'est comme sa conception il
vous qui avez vu quand même un certain
nombre de cas des théâtres samu ce qui
est d'ailleurs étonnant c'est qu'on n'a
pas du tout l'impression voyant les
spectacles en écoutant le langage donkey
très simple que les taxes ont réellement
écrit
ils sont à prix et qui sont répétés on a
l'impression d'assister une
improvisation fox et celle des secrets
aussi dit que cette heure alors donc on
se rend compte que le comédien du café
des arts de la dame qui sait tout faire
un bris quand j arrive à tout faire
enfin qui doit savoir c'est donc le côté
a priori un peu boy-scout qu' on aurait
pu vous plaquer comme ça rapidement
c'est complètement faux c'est une
nouvelle race de comédiens web de
comédiens j'en sais rien mais en tout
cas
homme d'affaires des petits commerçants
les problèmes psy commerçants on va en
parler justement d'un côté commerces
fermés le café théâtre c'est ça doit
être c'est un tremplin pour les jeunes
auteurs et à tremplin pour les jeunes
comédiens will all come back en somme
une s'agir de travailler pour les jeunes
comédiens à la rooney qui est super
fille disque depuis vous faites du café
théâtre on vous a fait des propositions
au travail pas mal aussi devrions tous
nous allons travailler beaucoup pour la
télévision en mono garcin j'ai travaillé
mais maintenant je suis je crois que le
café terre ce n'est pas un style de
settat c'est un style de vie c'est à
dire que je crois qu'on a un moment
donné comme un genre à lui tout à leur
redonner une envie d'exprimer des choses
on se rend compte que dans une certaine
un certain système soit possible alors
on cherche un voyeur c'est ce qui a
existé dans toutes les époques
alors moi je ne vais jetter la
télévision et j'étais dans une seringue
et puis je fais autre chose je crois que
d'autres étaient des copains moi j'ai un
caractère difficile je passe donc seule
la mère personnes pour l'instant et puis
etc mais je crois que c'est pas
forcément uniquement où l'improvisation
c'est rare on peut écrire des textes
très écrits et quand on en donne pas
l'impression ses saillies formidable et
c'est ça qui te salue certain qu'ils ont
sauvé leur tête
bon je disais tout à l'heure qui avait
20 café théâtre à paris alors il ya les
purs les vrais ceux qui travaillent un
collectif bien au chaud dans beaucoup
tout est très gentil ce soit et puis il
ya les autres moi je suis un peu étonné
quand je lis un petit revue on vous
donne
la liste de toutes les pièces de théâtre
tout ça quand je vois par exemple que
dans le café théâtre
vous avez mony dalmès mondial mais c'est
quand même une pension ex-pensionnaires
si je ne m'abuse du théâtre français
je m'attendais pas à la trouver dans la
capitale je vois qu'ils aient également
jean marc thibault je veux qu'on joue
également la voix humaine de jean
cocteau
ça ne me semble pas être une création
nouvelle enfin un esprit de vous alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça ou est-ce
qu'il ait l'esprit café théâtre
quand on voit des choses comme ça je le
fais aucune critique bien entendu quant
aux spectacles dont je viens de parler
simplement ça ne correspond pas du tout
à ce que vous voulez de me dire
donc je sais déjà bu aussi beaucoup de
gens qui trouvent pas d'endroit dans le
real alors une salle de café théâtre
fait l affaire même si elle est petite
il monte la pièce ils peuvent la montée
puisque ils ont une salle
et puis surtout ça coûte rien c'est vrai
qu'un petit café-théâtre coûte pas
grand-chose à monter il n'y a pas grand
risque à le faire au nom gagner 5000
nouveaux fonds on peut monter un
spectacle art au théâtre ça prendrait
pas je suis sûr qu'on peut remonter avec
2000 à leur côté at il faudrait à la
création anciens je suis d'accord mais
je crois qu'il ya ici même dans la tête
simplement dans la ville et des
comédiens qui peuvent être connues qui
peuvent être arrivé leur vie comme ça
une fois de temps en temps en 90 jours
un mois pendant un an de faire un autre
forme d'expression de trouver un moyen
plus libre on pourrait simplement de
jouer tous allez pouvoir dire son propre
texte un grand comédien qui veut dire
son propre texte qu'il a écrit que
parfois drôle tout seuls leurs a du mal
à trouver une grande salle de théâtre ou
à trouver un suspect sur ses cadres jean
marc thibault montée cocteau à mon avis
et des gens qu'on va trouver de théâtre
oui on peut aussi se dire mais c'était
parce que moi j'ai l'esprit très très
méchant est très mal tourné qui était un
homme enfant peut être aussi se dire que
comme le café théâtre ça marche très
très bien en france ça commence à très
bien marché à paris c'était une occasion
de se faire aussi de gagner un peu
d'argent
bon maintenant beaucoup de café théâtre
ça signifie beaucoup de public est un
public très nouveau j'imagine alors
comment réagissent ce public nouveau
comment comment
comment ça se passe t'il est ce que vous
avez des gens qui arrivent avec leurs
beaux costumes du dimanche et qui sont
un peu étonnés devant la manière que
vous allez présenter le spectacle
j'accepte les scandales parce que sa
part réservé et c'est déjà très bien
même s'il n'avait pas été saisie mais au
niveau du spectacle ils réagissent très
bien parce qu'il rit autant que tu n
importe quelle personne sous la personne
en sortant en trombe au nom pareil
l'aiment chaud alors le public évolue ça
dépend yade il ya des années où ces très
vieux pour nous c'est très vieux ça veut
dire entre ses 50 ans quoi alors 50 ans
il ya des gens de 50 ans mais s'il faut
le dire parce que avant on avait que des
gens de notre âge quand même c'était
rare les genres disons un peu plus âgé
et puis ça bouge à l'enm attendre à des
gens plus âgés on a même des gens du
troisième âge qui viennent et qui sont
ravis qu'ils sont les plus drôles d
encausse écoutant là ça a changé
puis alors on a des gens pour les
milieux effectivement parce qu'il faut
pas dire quelques unes qui a fait taire
c'est quelque chose de démocratique
ça reste un petit peu comme au théâtre
il ya une ouverture enfin c'est quand
même pas ouvert à tous rendez vous du
public je crois c'est de voir des gens
de province qui viennent pour une
occasion qu'elle comptait toujours sur
l'agriculteur ça peut être ça qui
viennent à paris et qui ont une liste de
choses qu'ils veulent voir et
entretiennent café-théâtre rencontre